احتدام القتال في دوم باث باتا وشيفا بعد
قيام روسيا بنقل قواتها العسكريه الجيش
الروسي يكثف منها شماته الصاروخيه في
الشرقي اوكرانيا بعد الانسحاب من خرسان
ضمن خطه الاستراتيجيه وتكتيكيه جديده تهدف
لتجاوز الهزائم الاخيره التي تم تسجيلها
وفقا ما نقلت صحيفه الامريكيه فخساره
منطقه خرسون شكلت ضربه كبيره لموسكو التي
قالت سابقا اذا الانسحاب من المنطقه جاء
لدواعي عسكريه و بهدف اخراج نحو 20 الف
جندي روسي كانوا في وضع الحرج غير ان
التطورات الحاصله في الميدان كشفت النيه
الحقيقيه لموسكو التي اعادت نشر الجنود في
جبهات اخرى منها منطقه دنياسك الشرقيه
وفقا ايضا لصحيفه حيث تشهد المناطق
القريبه من دنيا الياس في منطقه دونباس
الشرقيه
مدينتيكا ضربات صاروخيه روسيه متفرقه وقصف
مدفعي مك وتابعوني تطورات الحاصله اكدوا
ان الانسحاب الروسي من خيرسون سيسمح
للقوات الروسيه باعاده تنظيم صفوفها
وتعزيز سيطره على اجزاء من شرق وجنوبي
اوكرانيا في المرحله المقبله
[موسيقى]
قصيره وفتره راحه لاستعاده قوتها قد يطلق
شخص ما على ذلك نهايه للحرب لكن مثل هذه
المهله لن تؤدي الا الى تفاقم الوضع
التركيز المتجدد على جبهه القتال الشرقيه
اكدت روسيا التي تسعى للاستيلاء على منطقه
جمباز باكملها بعد ما اجبرت او اجبرت على
انسحاب بمنطقه كياب وشمال اوكرانيا في وقت
السابق في المرحله المقبله مشاهدينا وفقه
خبراء عسكريين ستكون حاسمه في الدومباس
حيث تتاهب القوه الاوكرانيه لصد الهجمات
الروسيه المحتمله بعد من ضمت قوات من
خيرسون الى المعركه جنبا الى جنب مع حوالي
300,000 رجل جندتهم روسيا مؤخرا بحيث
سيكون الجيش الروسي مجبرا على تحقيق مكاسب
ميدانيه وانشاء خطوط دفاعيه في جمباز بعد
التخلي عن مدينه خرسان لاقامتي مواقع
دفاعيه جديده على الضفه الشرقيه لنهر
النيترو غير ان عامل الطقس وهنا نتحدث عن
فصل الشتاء يمكن ان يجعل ذلك صعبا وسيؤدي
الى اعاقه استخدام المركب المركبات
والطائرات بدون طيار من الجانب الروسيه
فنائب وزير الدفاع الاوكراني فلوغيمير
هافري لوز اكد ان القوات الاوكرانيه قد
تصل الى شبه جزيره القرم التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا بحلول عيد الميلاد وتنهي الحرب
بحلول الربيع
[موسيقى]